shanon's with us and Columbus Ohio hi
Shannon how are you good afternoon how
can I help
okay I would call me because I just had
to file bankruptcy recently only thing
that I'm card to pay back now is certain
loans and I do have a car payment I just
wanted to know where would I start cuz I
just started reading a book which is
awesome and I need to know where do I
start and the baby said and I put myself
in these situations over and over again
for some reason these financial
situations and I went on 38 and I have
dipped into my 401k to where I don't
have any and is it too late for me to
really be financially stable stable like
I need to be there's not only your plan
you can certainly do it but obviously
you can't keep doing what you've been
doing it's not working whatever it was
it wasn't working we can readily assess
that I went bankrupt when I was in my
20s because I was stupid
and I ran up a bunch of debt and I made
a bunch of impulsive and bad decisions
and the one of the one of the huge
benefits of that wasn't hey it hurt
emotionally and spiritually and
relationally financially so bad that I
was bound to determinate it to to
whatever I used to do I was gonna do
exactly the opposite because everything
I used to do sucked and so I did an
autopsy on Dave and said okay this is
what killed the patient right and so one
of the things I figured out was credit
cards aren't a blessing another thing I
figured out is dead is not a way to
wealth and so I started studying I'm a
Christian so I started saying what the
Bible says about money and I started
finding a lot of it's way different than
what other people think or do but I
don't one of the benefits of being
bankrupt is you don't really care what
other people think you just want to win
right and that's where you are you're
calling me cuz you're disgusted in a
good way yes I am and I don't want to
keep putting myself back
situations amen and I love I love the
phrase you're using putting myself
nobody did it to you but you that's what
happened to me too so that's a big deal
to say okay I caused this but guess what
that means I can change it the biggest
controlling variable is controlling me
so all I gotta do is have a different
plan here okay let's walk through what
to do then what kind of debt did you
bankrupt on if you reaffirmed your car
and of course student loans aren't
bankrupt Abul so what did you bankrupt
owns credit cards I don't even think I
don't even have like a whole just a
whole bunch of credit cards doing favors
for people so what's the debt on the
bankruptcy that you filed I don't want
to include the student loan because I
still have to no no no that's new
tonight incur up those seventy like most
of it came from I did a favor for
somebody and let them get a rental car
in my name which was my fault and that
was like almost forty fifty thousand
dollars of it so I wrecked the car
exactly okay and then they came after
you okay so that's forty out of 70 what
was the other twenty or thirty it just
says credit cards okay making bad
choices with apartment saying not to be
doing everything I've done with all me
like choices that I made nobody did it
no with all me yeah but what you figured
out is is that no is a really powerful
word when somebody comes at you with a
stupid idea
like you renting a car for them in your
name right right correct
so no is a really powerful word a lot of
people have trouble saying no because
they're yeah they're just nice people
you're just a nice person and so I want
you to figure out that you're not being
nice to someone when you allow them to
financially abuse you when you don't say
no they allow you you taught they come
at you with a travel agent for guilt
trips right and they're gonna put you on
a guilt trip and you got to go oh well
you know no you don't it and family's
worse they'll do it to you big-time
so what is your household income right
now I make forty five thousand cool and
how much student loan debt do you still
have 45 and we own the stupid car Oh
about $20,000 you need to sell the car
it's too expensive
you don't need $20,000 car when you have
student loan debt coming out your ears
and you make forty five thousand it's
too expensive a car you need to get a
five thousand dollar car yeah you did
and you also know I'm right don't you
I know you're right because I totaled my
car in both this car so when I got money
back for the yard I asked myself should
I take this three thousand dollars in
and yourself told you right yeah okay so
here's what we're gonna do
it's time how old are you perfect it is
so high it is so time for you to change
I'm gonna put you through Financial
Peace University and I'm gonna pay for
it because I have been where you are
scared and confused and didn't know what
to do and I'm gonna show you exactly
what to do but you you listen to me
Shannon every single thing I tell you to
do you freakin do it okay okay and I'll
show you how to be a millionaire by the
time you're 58 okay you're gonna do this
but don't you screw around with my stuff
don't you say I did everything but I
don't wanna hear about butts you do
every single thing I tell you to do okay
okay and I'll help you turn this around
because I've been where you are I know
how it feels to be scared you hold on
and Kelly I'll pick up we'll get you in
Financial Peace University you can do
this and I'll be here to coach you and
also beer yell at you if you don't do it
so because I love you and I think you
can do this